you've got to see this show that that
Marty does with Steve Martin it's
fantastic it is if you get along very
well with Steve oh I love Steve I love
Steve he's one of the great guys you
know I've been through different times
and he's always been there with a warm
kind of cold bony hand at my shoulder as
he mimics human emotion you're saying
not mr. warmth that's what you say he is
the warmest the lovely guy and I've
learned a great deal from him in fact I
made a list of things you know sometimes
I jot things down when I'm being driven
and about Steve and I know things you
love about Steve Martin I've learned I
learned and loved and loved like Steve's
taught me at the exhilaration of nipple
clamps I didn't know that remember you
can edit this again again I love how
Steve can't pass wet cement without
drawing a penis you know not many people
can he does well anatomically correct
I've learned how Steve I learned from
Steve how much fun it is to teach babies
how to vape inhale yes I love let's see
that when he's at a dinner party he's
not afraid to yell oh I'm bored that's a
good one yeah I love how he's when
anyone mentions their wife Steve isn't
afraid to say had her first
see the most is he's not afraid to punch
someone else's kid
[Music]
on the subject of Steve Martin and
Martin Short they are on a national
comedy tour now you see them soon you
won't by the way you said national
holiday tour you did you did and I don't
want to say it's a problem but I'd phone
the doctor because I've been here lately
and I don't know I know it's the alcohol
sure but I also think and again if you
get mad at me this cuz it would be you
we're just people the dentures don't fit
anymore because mouths can change wait
wait the crowd is gasping like you've
revealed that I we're dancers well that
was too far you're not gonna go after
Conan's adult diaper are you I like that
you're drunk and diapers so there's two
reasons for you to talk exactly if you
look at the tape the playback and I know
you study it at night it's what it says
here it says Martin Short and Steve
Martin are in a national harmony tour
now you see them soon you won't because
legally you can't call what you guys do
comedy and
I was covering you I was legally
Reverend
oh no you didn't yes you now you can see
the May 8th in Wichita Kansas a ninth in
Kansas City Missouri May 23rd in
Rochester Minnesota and May 31st in El
Paso Texas like yeah I will say this
every now and then I have the honor of
getting to have a meal with you or
something and every time I leave that
experience and it's happened many many
times I get in my car and I call my wife
and I say I can't believe I know Martin
sure it's he's one of the he's a
legendary brilliant man and I cannot
believe I even know him